i get this note from gary yesterday and
it says hey
sal the stockbroker who works with us
wrote me this note
and i go let me what's the note
he goes sal is working
friday night somewhere and uh he needs a
place to stay cause he'll be working
late he wants to use your apartment
to crash oh my god i go gary it's a goof
and he goes no i don't think it's a goof
if i could take credit as a bit as if
being funny i'll say it's a bit but it
wasn't a bit
right so gary gary says to me it's not a
bit
sounds dead serious and and sal even
said to him
you know this is a really weird job he
goes
every he goes any job i ever had people
never told me i was inappropriate but
here every minute people are telling me
i'm inappropriate and saying weird
things
right why would i want you in my
apartment sleeping
it's not that i didn't have a place to
stay who cares
he really said he goes why is it so
weird because i think howard's going to
say yeah
why would i want him in my apartment
it's not that
what is it i have to i have to stay late
into the in the city tonight yeah i
don't want to stay at christie's place
because
he hasn't changed his sheets in three
weeks okay you were my last resort
i would never want to bother you i felt
uneasy i asked gary in advance
this is exactly what he told me he goes
listen it's not a big deal i'll stay in
the guest room
because i'll take a shower in the
morning then howard and i will jump in
the limo together and we'll come over
great
that's how you didn't say this all right
there is no way
no way no he's serious gary said
i said gary don't you know when you're
the victim of a joke how would it be
safe to say how we have a pretty
professional relationship off the
airport no oh okay
well no wouldn't be safe to say that you
know what i'm stuck
in the city i asked my boss howard stern
if i could crash first of all
and sleep in a bed i'm not your boss
you've never seen the apartment i
had visions of us hanging out laughing
watching survivor
i was gonna cook for you oh my god in
other words like we could sit and watch
tv together have some laughs with beth
watch survivor we both love it we both
talk about it insane
how am i insane you know what howard
i don't know oh yeah it's about a month
ago
you were a fan a super fan of the show
you still are now you're
now yeah unfortunately you're inside the
door somehow
somehow thank you why would you feel
comfortable enough
i don't i like to get more comfortable
with you why would you feel comfortable
asking me for a place to stay but not to
email me that note you had gary give it
to me no no he said to me that his email
was down so he forwarded it to me
he would have sent it directly to you
all right oh you're kidding me i told
gary no no benji's night is tonight to
stay over
the guest room is booked